meanwhile metro police are on the
lookout for the driver who hit
and killed a pedestrian and then took
off this is about 8 30 last night around
rancho in washington
now police say the pedestrian was in a
crosswalk that the lights were flashing
the man hit by a dark-colored sedan that
driver is the one that did not stop
but then the person was hit by a van the
driver of the van
did stick around not expected to face
charges
metro says this is the 28th deadly crash
in the jurisdiction so far this year
that's a lot more than at this time in
2020
and metro says that's troubling
this time last year things in the city
were shutting down
where now this year things are starting
to open up
and we hope that this deadly trend on
our roadway isn't something that
starts to build up as we start opening
up more lieutenant brooklyn urging
pedestrians be aware of your
surroundings and drivers
slow down where there might be
pedestrians especially at night again
for this hit and run that was fatal
metro police looking for a dark
colored sedan and probably going to have
some pretty big time front end damage
you have information
you're asked to call police john